hey folks compares here I thought I
would talk a little bit about
accelerated learning in specifically the
capacity of memorizing foreign
vocabularies how do you learn a language
a lot about this and I thought I was
terrible at languages up until about 15
I had done very poorly at Spanish and
when I moved from one school to another
I had a chance to choose from other
languages and since I had friends who
were going into Japanese I figured well
if I'm going to fail in languages
I might as well fail in a class for my
friends or at least in the same room I
went to Japanese and eventually went to
Japan as an exchange student and that
triggered an entire discovery of my own
ability to learn languages and your
ability to learn languages I was not bad
at languages I just had the wrong method
I had teachers who really weren't
enabling me to create approaches that
would make the language stick so I'm
going to help you with a few different
approaches and examples that I've used
over and over and over again so I'm not
going to talk about learning languages
ad nauseam in every respect because that
could be hours and hours long if you
want some of that I highly recommend
that you just go to Tim dot blog there's
a topics section and as language
learning I have a bunch of different
articles I've written as well as
articles by Benny Lewis who's fantastic
Irish polyglot is this nickname and a
handful of other folks which are
spectacular and have links and links and
links to tons of resources I'm going to
talk about vocab because most people are
very intimidated by learning a high
volume of words and if you approach it
the right way you can actually learn
hundreds of words per day if you wanted
to make that effectively your full time
job if you want to make it just a
part-time gig you can still learn ten to
a hundred words per day if you really
make an effort of it and if you do that
you don't have to learn 100 thousand
words to be functionally
conversationally fluent in a given
language meaning you can hold a long
conversation you really only need about
two thousand words very rough
approximation and there are some
fantastic flashcards for instance from
companies like vis vis
edie calm which compiles the flashcards
from high frequency word lists based on
usage in newspapers books and so on what
I would say though is that this is best
illustrated by example so rather than
wrote i IE the repetition of this in
english as this in spanish this in
english is this in spanish I'm just
hoping that that is going to gain a
foothold in your mind let's just say cow
and vaca da CA all right so vaca is
cattle vodka vodka cow etcetera
how would you remember this we are
highly visually adapted we are evolved
to be very visually acute and we are
driven that way and our memory is highly
tagged and cued by any type of imagery
so what I would suggest in such a case
so you use something that has been
nicknamed the link word mnemonic there
are other ways to label it really all
this entails is creating a link between
the words that is image based so if we
have a word like vodka and I would
encourage you when you're first learning
vocab to the extent possible not to
fixate on the spelling because it can
throw you off vodka vodka what does that
sound like vacuum maybe alright so what
could you imagine you could imagine cow
because you want to use the cue in
English because if you can recall the
Spanish let's say in this case from
English you can always recognize the
Spanish but not vice versa which is why
if you're looking in a book and it has
say the Spanish terms listed first and
then the English terms listed I wouldn't
use it I would switch the order so I
would even use a piece of paper
potentially to cover up the Spanish and
only use the English as a cue as your
native language
so vaca let's imagine that there is a
cow and it has a really oddly shaped
head that looks like the end of a vacuum
and it's sucking up the grass on the
ground
alright so it's cow with a head like a
vacuum sucking up grass cow vacuum vaca
alright that would be a very simple
example other approaches you could take
which are a little more flexible but
more or less the same thing if you have
something much more complicated so let's
say you have
a term like mol Makaha Cody mol Makaha
Cody is detached retina in Japanese so
number one you have something that's a
lot longer mol Makaha Cody alright I
hope that sound like an English not a
whole lot
it's also something a little more
complex detached retina and what you
realize quickly is that you you
generally just need a cue which is why
for instance you'll see a higher hit
rate on the Wheel of Fortune if you give
people the first few letters and then
say the last few letters so taking that
as analogy the way we would work with
that mol Makka pakka
what is the first part sound like mo mo
mo mo mo mo
okay maybe sounds like the moma so you
live in a place like San Francisco New
York and the Museum of Modern Art so it
sounds like the MoMA alright well you
could imagine then people walking into
the MoMA looking at displays and just
having their eyeballs blow out of their
head okay just imagine a bunch of people
walking into the MoMA and getting
detached retinas because their eyeballs
blow out of their heads like splatter
the paintings in front and then that
because you have MoMA there's a decent
chance that you will then remember mol
mcquoddy and in the case of say Japanese
you have the characters which you would
learn later and it becomes even easier
because you will be breaking that word
into mol Makaha Cody into a few
characters okay if you are learning so
that is how you would tackle say
something is slightly more complex in
terms of a longer word for instance if
you are learning a tonal language such
as Mandarin so I've studied Mandarin and
spend time in China to universities how
should you learn tones that is of course
part of learning the vocabulary this is
something that just slaughters a lot of
students of Chinese particularly if they
have lacks teachers number one you need
merciless hard-ass teachers because they
will bludgeon you and they should into
training your vocal cords to make the
proper sound I don't care how many times
you hear something like yes you if you
haven't developed the actual vocal cord
ability which is just like doing any
type of stretching or strength training
you have to
condition your threat to build make
those sounds you are Sol your [ __ ] out
of luck and if they don't reinforce that
and force you to get it correct and
train properly you're going to do a lot
of bad repetitions and I met many
students after six months of doing
Chinese had a ton of what they thought
was great vocabulary we went to China
and nobody understood a thing they were
saying they had to start from scratch so
don't do that now we come down to
choosing materials and what I would say
is that if possible and this is an
unpopular position but you want to use a
writing system in English so the Roman
izing of say Chinese that indicates the
tone in the spelling this is very
controversial there's a system for
instance called G R which stands for
voice romances and you would say have
first tone in Chinese fir wah wah gu o
then waa second tone should be country
like boy country language which is kind
of a long story and pissed off a bunch
of mainlanders but that's okay
so hua ji wo and then if I want to say
shape hua Sookie has gone I have gone or
fourth tun gu o H this helps
dramatically with memorization of vocab
and specifically retaining the tones the
more popular system that is used in
textbooks for Chinese for Mandarin
certainly probably for Cantonese - is
pinyin pinyin is where you would have
say this wall and then they would use a
diacritical mark at the top to say wah
second tone or fourth tone war with
these funky little lines on the top and
the bottom students do not remember that
stuff from all I can tell and everything
I've seen the problem is as a teacher in
a university you are oftentimes rewarded
by how many students you can keep in a
class or get to a passing grade gr is a
huge pain in the ass and the
but if we're thinking like Abe Lincoln
if I'm given six hours to chop down a
tree I'll spend the first four hours
sharpening the axe you want to do the
heavy lifting in the beginning so that
you can have a much smoother ride later
on and in a total language part of that
is choosing the right romanization of
that language and in my opinion gr is
highly highly highly underrated it's
just a huge pain in the ass in the
beginning so you'll be very frustrated
for the first couple of weeks maybe and
then looking back if you actually stick
with it you'll think yourself my god
that was just a divine gift that I
learned a gr instead of pinyon all right
and then there are of course the tools
that if you want to space your
repetition even if it's practicing the
recall of something like cow in Spanish
what was that cow vacuum vaca right or
if you're trying to think ah detached
retina which probably won't have much
use for but I learned it because I read
comic books I had a lot of fighting in
them to learn instance we talked about
detached retinas a fair amount well
detached retinas blowing onto the
paintings we're at the MoMA mole moth
kouhaku Timo McCarthy is detached retina
alright but you still have to figure out
how frequently how often to use these
types of say flashcards or cues remember
they're going to look at the English
first not the target language first and
there are many different things you can
use you could read an article say and
Wired magazine written about supermemo
which is very fascinating spaced
repetition approach supermemo which has
then been turned into say software
programs and apps like unki a and ki
which in Japanese is actually rote
memorization so that's there's some
irony to that but unki a and ki and then
of course and I'm biased here because
I've been involved with the company and
help them duolingo it is the most
popular free language learning software
on the planet 100 million plus users and
they also have a separate app that is
used for flashcards so there are many
different ways to approach this many
ways to learn languages but it is my my
firm belief that if you approach it in a
rational
a methodical way that you can become
conversationally fluent in just about
any language in 8 to 12 weeks and that
is coming from someone who quit gave up
on Spanish for years and years and years
but now having practiced with Chinese
Japanese Spanish Italian Portuguese
Indonesian ie bahasa I've played with
and toyed with Turkish Greek all these
languages for just a few weeks at a time
for fun in many cases I believe 812
weeks you can be conversationally fluent
or very least functional in almost any
language certainly any language that I
become so that should be very reassuring
you can tackle many many languages not
just one and if you learn another
language just one additional language
you have a brand new lens through which
to view everything in life your chin
your thinking changes your perspective
changes your empathy changes so if
you're trying to figure out a way to
hack your life span thing Valley's drugs
metformin rapamycin whatever you think
about all these ways you might double
your life span well one way you can do
it right now is by learning a second
language so Godspeed good luck I hope
that helps there and if you want more on
mnemonic devices certainly I wrote quite
a bit about mnemonic devices and
learning things like languages in the
4-hour chef because it's actually booked
on accelerated learning there's also a
fantastic book by I believe the name is
Higby I haven't read it in decades your
memory and how to improve it it's an
excellent excellent book on tactical and
very concrete mnemonic devices that have
been used for centuries that are very
easy to implement so there you have
folks good luck
gum but they go as high as they would
say in Japanese good luck or add oil
that means good luck in Chinese yah yah
yah yah yah yah yah hope you enjoyed the
video if you would like to see my
favorite piece of content that I put out
every week it is a short newsletter five
bullet Friday it's free five bullet
points with the coolest things that I
have been finding using testing in a
given week I put it out every Friday you
can digest it about five minutes take a
look
Bible of Friday